des annonces il attendu mais pas de
troisième confinement selon le premier
ministre il est encore temps d'y
échapper
nous en connaissons l'impact très lourd
pour les français sur tous les plans
ce soir nous considérons au regard des
chiffres des derniers jours que nous
pouvons encore nous donnait une chance
de l'éviter
jean castex a annoncé une série de
restrictions
dès dimanche les frontières seront
fermés aux voyageurs venant de pays
extérieurs à l'union européenne
toute entrée ou sortie du territoire
sera désormais interdite sauf motif
impérieux y compris en outre-mer
les voyageurs venant de pays de l'ue eux
devront présenter un test pcr négatif
récent certains espaces commerciaux vont
également fermer dès dimanche les
centres commerciaux non alimentaire
d'une surface supérieure à vingt mille
mètres carrés c'est à dire ceux qui
favorisent le plus de brassage des
populations seront fermés le premier
ministre a également appelé au
renforcement du télétravail dans les
entreprises des mesures complémentaires
ou couvre-feu qui arrive trop tard selon
l'opposition notamment vis-à-vis de la
fermeture des frontières
ce tweet un an jour pour jour les
membres du gouvernement rien au nez de
ceux qui réclamaient cette mesure de bon
sens emmanuel macron nous expliquait
doctement que le virus n'avait pas de
passeport
un an pour qu'ils admettent l'évidence
et protège les français
d'autres estiment qu'en faisant planer
la menace d'un confinement
le gouvernement joue avec les nerfs des
français tout ça pour ça
la france ne risque pas de reprendre le
contrôle sur l'épidémie et de rassurer
les français avec ces mesures rien sur
la campagne de vaccination est pas de
sortie du tunnel en vue tout ça pour ça
je trouve particulièrement dangereux de
jouer sur la corde psychologique des
français en faisant monter la menace du
confinement ces derniers jours pour
finalement envoyé à la volée un premier
ministre embarrassé faire des annonces
mineurs
le medef a lui estimé qu en conciliant
exigences sanitaires et économiques
le gouvernement tire les leçons des deux
premiers confinement des mesures qui
arrive comme un compromis alors que des
voies politiques et scientifiques
demandé depuis un moment
la fermeture des commerces ou encore des
écoles